au début ça a été assez compliqué parce
que elle nous a fait croire qu'elle
était elle-même victime d'une arnaque
aux faux bail ce qui est quelque chose
qui existe c'est connu des services de
police je l'a expliqué après en effet il
ya des gens comme ça qui forcent la
porte qui font venir une dizaine de
personnes pour visiter ils leur font un
faux bail ils font payer trois mois de
loyer en liquide et puis disparaissent
dans la nature donc elle nous a fait
croire ça et du coup quand je dis nous
c'était moi et l agence de location et
du coup on a été un petit peu comment
dire on a un petit peu prise en pitié
évidemment et on a essayé de l'aider à
se reloger ailleurs on a tenté tout un
tas de choses toutes faites ou enfin
beaucoup de beaucoup d échanges de
médiation etc et jusqu'au jour où en
fait on lui a trouvé un autre
appartement on lui a demandé de venir
pour visiter l'appartement pour savoir
si ça lui convenait parce qu'en plus on
a été jusque là et elle s'est pas
présenté et là j'ai compris que c'était
que tout ça était faux que c'était un
escroc et du coup j'ai été porté plainte
à la police là
la police ils ont refusé de prendre ma
plainte tout simplement parce que
c'était pas ma résidence principale donc
ça déjà je trouve ça complètement
aberrant on a le droit de forcer la
porte de quelqu'un parce que c'est pas
sa résidence principale
suite à ça j'ai appris qu'en fait je
pouvais pas la faire partir que je
pouvais rien faire en fait et que je
devais attendre alors à l'époque qu'il
fallait un procès donc j'ai eu un ordre
énorme énorme dans un juge quelques mois
plus tard qui a
qui a décidé qu'elle était expulsable
immédiatement sans préavis sans en tenir
compte de la trêve hivernale puisque
c'était un occupant sans droit ni titre
le problème c'est que partant de là une
fois que le juge a ordonné l'expulsion
il faut que leurs données soient
appliquées et c'est le préfet qui décide
d'appliquer ou pas ou quand il va
appliquer la décision du juge ce qui est
absolument incroyable enfin pour moi
c'est aberrant je dirais à ce moment là
à quoi sert le jugent bon et puis ce qui
s'est passé c'est que là le préfet a
décidé que ben non on expulserait pas en
vertu de la loi dalo qui est le droit au
logement opposable
mère célibataire
avec un enfant en bas âge
bah on n'expulse pas je me suis à ce
moment-là renseigner auprès des services
sociaux pour savoir combien de temps ça
va durer en fait dans combien de temps
vous allez lui trouver une solution de
relogement pérenne qui fera que je
pourrais lui demander de partir de chez
moi et là on m'a dit ben vu la situation
du logement social en france et en
région parisienne en particulier ça peut
durer des années
moi pendant ce temps là
j'avais pas de revenus pas de revenus
locatifs je pouvais plus payer mon loyer
chez moi parce que je suis locataire moi
de mon appartement encore et je me suis
retrouvé le mouvement bailleur a lancé
une procédure d'expulsion à mon encontre
et a joué aussi non mais c'est
complètement ubuesque c'est pas possible
cercle elle est chez moi moi comme elle
est chez moi je peux pas payer mon loyer
et c'est moi qui vais me retrouver à la
rue
donc seulement juste aurait eu baisse
comme si c'est vraiment et
hélas du coup j'ai contacté la presse en
disant mais des mois au secours c'est
quelque chose quoi évidemment ça a porté
ses fruits parce que la presse on sait
que ça marche et du coup là le préfet a
accepté enfin de jean thiffault la
pression il faut la pression un journal
ou de plusieurs journaux pour que le
préfet applique tout à fait la loi et
fasse respecter vos droits de
propriétaire tout à fait bah c'est à
dire que pour le coup on se dit que
finalement on n'a pas tellement de droit
en tant que propriétaire finalement bien
quoi dans l'histoire édifiante parce
qu'on apprend on apprend beaucoup de
choses du point de vue de la légalité
mois que j'ignorais